you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up are we on the
brink of a new coal mine in britain the
first in decades
five more years for emmanuel macron but
will he get france's climate commitments
on track
small behavioural changes that will save
money on your energy bills and reduce
carbon emissions
and meat made in space but can lab grown
meat ever take off
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world hear from
the people being hit hardest by those
changes and report on the race for
solutions
now a deadline by which the government
should decide whether or not to approve
a new coal mine in cumbria is fast
approaching
whitehaven mine to exploit coking coal
for industrial use would be the first
new coal mine to open in this country
for more than 30 years and according to
newspaper reports the government is
leaning towards approving the new site
its supporters say it would prove
invaluable in reducing reliance on
russian coal it would provide hundreds
of local jobs and the producing coal in
the uk would be better for the climate
than importing it well with me is our
climate reporter victoria seabrook so
victoria those are the arguments put
forward by its supporters but there are
a lot of people who oppose this new coal
mine aren't there
yes that's right so bear in mind that
this coal is going to be used in steel
production which which needs a lot of
coal it's very energy intensive let's
just take all of those three points that
you made in turn so first of all in
terms of getting off russian coal last
year the uk did get a lot of this kind
of coal from russia around 40
but actually since russia invaded
ukraine the british steel industry has
already managed to ditch imports of this
kind of russian coal and get it from
elsewhere mainly australia and north
america
then in terms of jobs west cumbria
mining says this will create 500 jobs
400 of those would be local quite a lot
of them would be underground and there
are some questions about how desirable
these kinds of jobs are given that this
is a declining industry and isn't going
to be around all that much longer if the
uk is to meet its climate climate
targets and then crucially on the
climate and emissions from there is a
there is an argument that of course
producing this kind of coal domestically
lowers emissions in comparison with
shipping in from the other side of the
world potentially but west cumbria
mining the company behind this this
project says that something like 87 of
this coal is going to be exported anyway
it's going to be sold on international
markets
and the government's climate advisors
the climate change committee has warned
that this mine would have an appreciable
impact on the uk's own emissions targets
and then finally it's just worth
remembering that the uk when it hosted
cop 26 the big climate summit in glasgow
last year it went around the world
lobbying other countries trying to
persuade them to give up coal and ditch
it so it's quite hard to see how it
would reconcile having lobbied other
countries to do that and then
potentially going ahead and approving a
new coal mine here in the uk
victoria thank you
emmanuel macron has won a second term as
president of france promising voters
that his new prime minister will take
personal charge of the environment brief
climate change didn't play a big role in
the campaign but it was top of the list
of voters concerns alongside the cost of
living our international affairs editor
dominick wagon reports from paris
i think there are reasons to be
skeptical if not cynical about emmanuel
macron's climate change credentials a
french court recently ruled that france
under his presidency has not done enough
to meet its mandated climate change
goals and he only really came to the
issue in the last week of the campaign
when he promised to build 15 nuclear
power stations and
50 wind farms having said all that
marine le pen his rival would have been
a lot worse for the environment and for
climate because she didn't seem to have
much time for the issue in her campaign
only really talked about it in terms of
her opposition to the international free
trade system and she like donald trump
on the other side of the atlantic has a
pet peeve about wind farms i think the
question about manny macron that
particularly young french voters want
answered as has he seen the lice is he
convinced enough about the cause of
climate change to put his full weight
behind it not just in france but also in
europe he's undoubtedly going to have a
powerful position in europe now that
he's been re-elected and with the german
chancellor distracted by things like
ukraine and russian gas he has a
position to make a huge difference in
france
and in europe but i think french voters
are skeptical because he's seen as
coming from an industrialist banking
background he's seen as elitist so they
need to be convinced that he has seen
the light and i think they think the
jury is still out he's got a lot of
convincing to do
let's get some on today's other climate
news now and a new poll has found that
the conservatives would lose two in five
2019 voters if the party ditched net
zero plans the results published by the
think tank onward found that the net
zero policy which commits the government
to huge reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions is deemed so important that 58
of people would pay more to reach the
uk's 2050 target
a further 68 of people polled said that
the uk should move faster towards net
zero and restrict russian gas exports
even if it makes bills more expensive
green priest activists have today
blocked a tanker from delivering russian
oil to norway protesters chained
themselves to the vessel's anchor chain
in slogan oil terminal as they attempted
to prevent the off-loading of 95 000
tons of oil the group is calling for the
norwegian government to ban imports of
russian fossil fuels following the
invasion of ukraine
wildfires have been sweeping through the
west and southwest of the united states
as dry and windy conditions have created
a dangerously early fire season
arizona new mexico and colorado have
been battling to contain fires across
different parts of the states which have
left at least one person dead and
destroyed hundreds of structures
rising temperatures attributed to
climate change are prolonging fire
seasons and making blazes more intense
now energy bills are rocketing the price
cap went up by around 50 percent at the
start of this month and looks set to
increase again in october
now we've talked a lot about measures
that homeowners can take to reduce those
bills and the resulting carbon emissions
but those tend to come cost a lot of
money solar panels heat pumps and
insulation
but there are behavioral changes that we
can all make which would save both money
and emissions
so if we take a look at this char the
huge majority of our energy is being
used for heating now that's where the
majority of our savings would then come
from and you can see clearly here that
more than two-thirds of the country's
annual gas consumption happens between
november and february so perhaps
unsurprisingly the top behavioral change
would be turning down the thermostat by
two degrees and that could save the
average household more than 200 pounds
and of course turning it down by just
one degree would save more than 100
pounds
but electricity is still much more
expensive than gas so
activities like not using a tumble dryer
putting your fridge in a cool place and
installing a water efficient shower head
could save us all money and reduce our
greenhouse gas emissions
so in total this is the amount of gas
that we use in this country and those
top five behavioral changes could save
up to a sixth of total gas consumption
that's the area there in blue the
savings
well jason palmer is director of
cambridge architectural research and
cambridge energy and conducted the
original research a decade ago on which
our updated charts are based
so the first question to you i guess
jason is has very much changed in the
past 10 years in terms of advice though
the advice hasn't changed a huge amount
now um we would still give very similar
recommendations and what people could do
today is actually very simple very
similar to the kind of actions that we
were recommending back in 2012 but what
has changed in the meantime is a number
of things and first of all the number of
households has increased so there's some
getting up for a 1.2 million more homes
more households now than there were in
2012. um the weather is a little bit
milder in winter than it was then homes
are a little better insulated than they
were back then um they're also better
controlled so heating systems now are
slightly better controlled than there
were back in 2012. it's more common now
to have room thermostats and timers
being used uh more commons have uh
thermostatic radiator valves trv is
controlling the temperature of
individual uh radiators which wasn't so
common back in 2012 but as i say overall
the advice that we give today is
remarkably similar to the way it was in
2012. one other significant change is is
the the shift from incandescent from old
style light bulbs
that worked using tungsten switching
over to either complex fluorescence or
in some cases leds and that meant a big
big saving on electricity consumption
over that period
well that's really interesting and the
behavioral changes that you've put
forward are are very simple as we said
but longer term are people actually
going to have to spend more money if
they're going to make a real difference
to their energy production and
by
by extension to emissions as well
they're going to have to invest in solar
panels or heat pumps for example
yes so um you're right there
there's a range of different actions
people can take from uh the very low
cost
actions that we looked at looked at in
our reports on behaviors through the
medium cost
upgrades things like changing heating
controls so improving making sure that
you have got
radiator valves on all of your radiators
more sophisticated controls that mean
you're not necessarily heating all zones
in your home um continuously but you're
able to separately set the
temperatures in your bedrooms from
living spaces kitchens and so on
differently fruits are higher cross
improvements including things like
either more efficient boilers or ideally
even heat pumps because heat pumps can
be a really big benefit and they really
are a major opportunity to bring down
carbon emissions
and do you think that that simple
message for the short term of the
behavioral changes are being properly
communicated to people do you think most
people know them already
no i really don't know and i still think
there are huge opportunities in homes
but also in businesses to save a lot of
energy and our work suggests that most
households and those businesses could
say getting onto ten percent in some
cases more than ten percent of their
their energy bills by looking at these
kind of everyday uh housekeeping issues
making sure that they're not heating
homes warmer than they need to be
making sure they're not heating rooms
that are unoccupied and perhaps thinking
about
lighting and the most efficient
appliances
okay jason palmer all very good tips
thanks very much indeed for your time
today
now we're one step closer to being able
to make meat in space after cow cells
matured at the international space
station returned to earth today the
experiment was carried out by aleph
farms an israeli company that
specializes in growing meat from cells
they say they want to create a meat that
doesn't rely on the weather or the
availability of natural resources and
they claim their process results in zero
waste and zero emissions unlike
traditional livestock farming which is
responsible for over 30 percent of
global methane emissions
do stay with us coming up i'll be joined
by bernice lee from chatham house and
tom burke from the e3g think tank and
we're going to be discussing that story
lab-grown meat might it be good for the
planet but will humans ever actually
take it up we'll be talking about that
in just a moment
[Music]
the reality is there's too many
streaming services and if you don't have
um
product or shows that people want to
watch on those services people soon turn
off because it's it's either get a
netflix subscription or eat in some
people's cases so there's a cost of
living situation going on here and i
also think probably from my uh my view
and i've got the arcade machines behind
me i don't necessarily think that
netflix has made the greatest views on
what its programming are it's trying to
broaden its audience at the moment it's
trying to move away from the people like
me who love the adam sandler films and
that's an important stat because they
made they invested millions of dollars
in adam sandler because they knew their
viewers were watching adam sandler films
we were all questioning why they were
doing it but it was because they have
all the statistics about who was
watching what and when they were
watching it so they're very savvy at
deciding what comes and what goes
perhaps much quicker than other
broadcasters because they're getting all
of this instant feedback
that's the cost of living versus the
cost of streaming it's one of the first
things that goes because you don't have
a long subscription the reality is five
years ago i had a sky subscription and i
probably i may have had one other one
other streaming subscription then now in
2022 i've got at least five streaming
subscriptions alongside my sky
subscription and the cost of viewing has
not stayed in line you're now paying an
additional amount of money for all of
these services and i think that's the
challenge here is none of them have yet
reached the sweet spot netflix has this
incredible habit of increasing the price
when i started watching netflix i think
i was paying a fiver a month i think
it's now about 15 pounds a month so
there's this increasing cost and the
other thing that's been largely unspoken
about with netflix till now and they're
now speaking about it is the number of
people sharing a password they say
they're now in 220 million homes where
they have subscribers but they've also
now admitted they've got 100 million
people watching subscriptions twice so
they may have 300 million people
watching but only 200 million people
globally are paying and this is going to
be the next big issue everybody who's
been lending a lending in quotation
marks a password to other people are
going to find soon they're going to be
locked out netflix are also moving into
video gaming as well which shows you
perhaps the streaming of films and tv
content might not be the only place
where they want to be
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to the climate issues
of the day now with bernice lee from
chatham house and tom burke of e3g a
climate change think tank good evening
to both of you nice to see you
both so reports are bound that the
government is set to approve a new coal
mine in cumbria it will be the first new
coal mine in the country in decades and
in theory it will provide coking coal
that's used in steel manufacturing
so bernice lee unconfirmed reports that
this might be about to get the nod
do you have any sympathy with the
arguments for it
look obviously it says that it will have
500 jobs and this is important to
remember all jobs matter but at the same
time if we care about jobs it's pretty
clear that the company hasn't really
made a commitment yet for the 500 jobs
and as a reporter said earlier on about
a fifth of those wouldn't be local
anyways so therefore even though we
really care about jobs if you care about
the sustainability of the jobs how long
it will last it is quite important to
remind ourselves that if indeed that we
haven't approved the mind yet and at the
same time if by 2035 i think climate
change committee says that we will
unlikely to be using much more cooking
coal so these are jobs that would last
at most for 15 years so therefore it is
while this is important to be mindful of
the employment benefits it's not clear
that it will actually bring that much
local employment benefits on time and
for a very sustainable future for any of
them either
and tom what do you make of these
arguments that it would help reduce our
reliance on importing russian coal which
obviously is seen as being hugely
important since the invasion of ukraine
but also that it'd be greener to produce
it domestically rather than transport it
from across the world i mean it's for
the steel industry which still relies on
coal at the moment doesn't it
uh the steel industry does rely on some
coal for uh smelting that's right but i
think victoria's report really blew a
hole in those arguments uh the steel
industry in britain's already moved away
from russian coal and as victoria
pointed out
most of the coal from the mine will be
exported so you will use an enormous
amount of uh carbon exporting that coal
far more than you would save by just
using our domestically ground coal so it
really is a bit of a nonsense this
argument but much more importantly as
victoria pointed out in her piece
this government along with the canadian
government has put together a really
powerful alliance of countries and
others to drive coal out of the economy
now how on earth can it possibly be
credible leading that alliance at the
same time as it's opening up a coal mine
itself so it's another kind of example
of of britain trying to say to the world
you know well one rule for uh you and
another rule completely for us
do you think that's right bernice or do
you think that some people will say it's
just one coal mine it's not going to
make a huge difference to our climate
target so how much does it matter
look i mean as tom just said obviously
it is important that we are we are doing
what we preach also at the same time if
we really care about the future of steel
which we should care about because we
would need steel then we will we should
note that there are already countries
like germany and sweden already have
commercial scale green steel production
using hydrogen hydrogen so if we are
going to spend resources on supporting
steel production it should be for steel
for the future and not the one that is
about to be sunset
well yes what do you make of that tom i
mean how advanced are we in this green
steel production how green is it
uh bernice is absolutely right our steel
production is not
very green it's also
we've got a rather small
by global standard steel industry and if
what one does is simply let them go on
as they are it'll get left even further
behind as the rest of the world moves
forward with uh decarbonized steel
production and that's what you can quite
clearly see the markets of the future
are going to want there's going to be a
big market for steel so bernice is right
to say that it's important that we find
the way to decarbonize steel
but it's not very good for britain to
give people the illusion that they can
go forward in a way that's carbon
intensive while the rest of the world is
moving in a much more uh clever and much
more viable direction
and bernice do you think that the war in
ukraine has changed a lot in terms of
how people view energy people are
looking in terms of a short-term crisis
and certain decisions might be made that
wouldn't have been last year
when they would have taken the climate
considerations that they would be more
pressing do you think that things have
changed if temporarily
it is not ever going to be a quick and
easy solution but at the same time it is
certainly strengthening the result of
those who believe that indeed renewable
energy clean energy are safer and
cleaner and better and therefore we must
get on with it as soon as we can
tom do you think that it's changed our
points of view
it's really been an enormous wake-up
call for us in order to make sure that
our energy system is secure we need to
really do all the kind of things jason
was talking about first and foremost and
that's reduce our
energy bills and our vulnerability to uh
international commodity prices and are
dangerous to the climate by doing the
things that we can do ourselves in our
own homes to make us our homes more
efficient but much more importantly than
that we need government to actually
invest in energy efficiency as the
cheapest and fastest way to drive bills
down and deal with climate change ten
years ago we were insulating about two
and a half million homes a year
government changed its policy and we're
now insulating less than 20 000 so
government policy is moving in the wrong
direction even actually as we see from
what consumers are doing they're trying
to do their best in order to reduce our
vulnerability both on security plans and
on climate grounds i'm just going to
speed up there we'll talk about
insulation another day i'm sure we'll
come back to that one but we want to
talk about meat now because we could be
one step closer to eating lab made meat
after cow cells matured in space arrived
back on earth today now the company
conducting the experiment hopes that
this could be a step forward for the
space travelers of the future but it
also says that making meat this way
could save this planet by cutting
emissions so bernice leaving aside the
space aspect for the moment
what do you think do you think that
lab-grown meat could be the answer to
our diet-related environmental issues
i mean as we know there are never one
answer there's never one answer but
actually it could be definitely one of
the answers i think it is already
approved i think in singapore from i
think end of 2020 and i think one of my
colleagues described it as a sort of
microbrewery version with a bioreactor
producing that grown meat in singapore
so i think that if the industry managed
to indeed prove that it can deliver what
it says on the tin and is transparent
about all of the environmental
legacy environmental outcomes and the
social outcomes as well meaning that it
is producing meat in a way that produces
less carbon using less water using less
land and is in fact going to be able to
be produced in such a way that avoids a
sort of concentration of power that we
know you know meat industry i think meat
is produced literally about like five i
mean sorry i'm exaggerating but it's a
very small number of producers producing
a lot more wells meat so if it could
actually avoid all the negatives of
conventional meat production and indeed
provide the nutrition that folks would
like and it's gonna be at a cost that is
agreeable and i can see that down the
line it could be definitely one of the
options
tom
yeah i agree with bernice about this we
are traveling on spaceship earth as it
used to be called uh it's a closed cycle
much like a spaceship it's just got
eight billion people on it and if we go
on increasing the amount of meat we eat
then we will find it impossible to live
on that spaceship so this is something
that's certainly worth exploring but i
think as bernice was correct to point
out before you go to scale on a new idea
like this you want to be absolutely sure
you thought of all the possible uh
things that might when you go to scale
might work really well in the lab but
may not work quite so well when they've
become the world's become wholly reliant
on them so we want to be sure before we
leave off okay into this thing that
we've fully understood the impact on the
environment otherwise all we're doing is
changing one problem for another problem
but certainly worth exploring yes and be
fascinating to see what people make of
it whether they fancy the idea of it
that's a whole other issue as well isn't
it but uh we'll discuss that another
time too uh well i can see you've got
something to say about it tom we'll find
out next time whether you'll be ordering
it
i was just gonna say people often worry
about people but if you think of the way
diets have changed in britain alone over
the last 20 years it's been quite
extraordinary how willing people are to
change their diet so i'm not sure that
it's the public that's the problem here
it's really the people who manufacture
the the food and the way in which that's
promoted i suspect as we've found a lot
of other things when the public has
asked to do it spit it's on the whole
quite willing to do so very interesting
okay we will leave it there tom bernice
lee always good to see you both thanks
very much indeed
so coming up on tomorrow's show i'm
going to be joined by helen clarkson
from the climate group and morgan
gillespie from the world resources
institute but that's from it from me for
now thanks for watching i'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you